why am i dancing i can't help it i can't
help it i got my tight pants on
we've got some amazing show for you
today
everybody's in constant weight you have
to take a look at this
hold on oh first of all we've got casey
becker i love mia casey becker
um you madam in the warhol maryland
situation
you're a beekeeper you look amazing
there's an
e full-blown e.t sir
your ghoul makeup is on point and then
we have mrs jets
which i love that this is so exciting
okay you know what this week is guys
you brought it because it's drew scary
more week
that's right i am a halloween enthusiast
and we're gonna make the set spooky all
week we kicked it off last night
with a big old cbs sunday night movies
premiere of scream
and we're gonna be doing this all week
long we've got costume contests
it's gonna go off all right in the news
though
i have to say i was really excited
because adele
was on saturday night live this weekend
and she did this
amazing bachelorette sketch and
you know here on this show we're doing a
whole bachelorette bonanza because i've
never seen it
and i'm a newbie and when i think like
oh adele
and snl are doing bachelorette then
clearly we're playing with the cool kids
so i'm
super excited about we're gonna talk
about it on the news this week tomorrow
night's episode
here we go okay chloe fineman are you
watching
i love you um all right oh wait is
somebody watching snl this weekend susie
from oregon
where are you right here oh you're the
beekeeper
i love beekeepers i actually i did i did
beekeeping in france once
yes to train forever after because we
had a scene and they
they had me fully 10 bees it turns out
that
a lot of smoke calms them down i'm like
yeah you and everyone else
um what uh yeah exactly
exactly um did you watch
snl yes of course and did you see the
adele bachelorette sketch hello
it's me yes who are you voting for in
the bachelor or
do you watch the bachelor too yeah of
course
anyone you think is gonna win this year
i
i really don't know i vote for somebody
and then i get a little disappointed
so i'm not sure i really hope for her
though okay
well we're gonna hopefully yes this
season's looking bananas but i got
[Music]
excited
you